normally for most North Koreans it's a
very difficult to living the country but
crossing the border because there's
military guards are watching patrolling
the border all the time especially when
they're ready intensive during games on
air games on one period it's changes a
lot these days more difficult to live
the country but at that time since
because I was living near the border
which means we have a very good
relationship with the border girls there
were military guards but like me some of
them was like uncle some of them like
older brother that's why we kind of
share the friendship together 10 family
between them so yeah he led me let me to
cross the border so actually I when I
cross the border was a very easy than
anyone because he was watching me too
behind and then he even guided me to let
me cross safely he would think but
escaping was the hard part
yes but it actually sounds like it was
the time after that almost as
challenging of course I was thinking you
know I saw brilliant a bright a new
world through the border so what I saw
was the the most beautiful world
compared to my country but I didn't know
that this behind us in behind the
brilliant new world what is waiting me
you know I thought that's all for me you
know maybe that's for everyone but once
I cross the border into China I realized
I was an illegal migrant in their
country I had to hide my identity even
you know it's breathing is a difficult
for me so the brilliant a new world is
not for me cisterna for no skin the
factor at all so that's why from that
time i had a really difficult life I
mean I was a hunted by the North Korean
Chinese authorities all the time simply
because I was a North Korean defector
and eventually I was caught by the time
its poorest even but I was very lucky
because I narrowly avoided being
repeat rate to North Korea by convincing
them that I was a tiny citizen because
at the time my Chinese language
abilities were enough to speaking
naturally with them including writing
including reading papers so it's really
another arm another miracle moment I
made by learning all the Chinese so I
could escape at the moment I mean in
that situation when I was caught by the
Chinese police there's not only one
police was there there's a to me around
30 policemen was in the one room I was
interrogated by so many police the
portsmen together so in that situation
is a most defectors I bet 100 the
[ __ ] will be sent back to North Korea
so I was a very very lucky one who can
make a avoid and despite knowing the
risks of being repatriated to North
Korea he still went back to get your mum
and your brother out and that in itself
is dangerous wasn't it yeah because of I
mean by later 10 years later I sick
asylum - so spirit again since we've
been divided for so long and still
Security's in my country half the half
percent percent of my country so I just
went there but my life I mean I can't
enjoy my life myself because of because
of me my family in North Korea they have
been having problem every year it's
continuously it what we never end what I
found because of the government just
watching my family very severely and
then they to avoid their problem they
need gave a lot of bribes and money
everything so I had to I mean I'm the
reason I am living in this world not
only for myself
now family meant to me everything I can
do everything for my family so in 2008
the end of 2009 when I arrived at
arrived in South Korea I made a big mind
big decision to take another risk my
life
and then which I did but again I didn't
know the where the helping my family to
make them into guide them freedom how it
be difficult
I couldn't never guess I know that's not
easy maybe I need to take another life
with my life but I thought I believed in
my look maybe you know I'm looking cool
like what happened in the past in
Chinese sports station maybe miracle
going to happen in my life again so I
just have believed in my luck and then I
hoped there's no more hardships in my
life again and I went there but I mean
there's none on my side I bring through
so many difficult time throughout that
I'm just
every single steps I've been crossed at
the time from Boulder near the border
with China to through China and the Laos
and Korea sorts great Indians it's such
a that's why that's the most painful
memory to me you know that I don't want
to get through again in my life but
having been through all those painful
memories and some of the things you
describe in your childhood as well are
just awful executions that you witness
for example why do you decide to write
about it and talk about it to the whole
world because that must be difficult are
they in the world they know while North
Korea and then they know about the Kim
regime the dictators and then they're
always talking about nucleus or the
missiles of a North Korea but many of
them they're not really they forgot
about the North Korean citizens to
ordinary people who was suffering under
the regime so by writing my book I
wanted to raise awareness so that I want
to let people I want to inspire people
to get involved in some ways to help
North Korean people either not getting
the factors in time
has that brought risks to you I mean are
you getting attention perhaps even
threats from the Kim regime of course
uncle and then I'm not that brave I'm
not the fighter I'm scared about that
actually that's the biggest concern
actually I mean which my mom also
worries the most of time with that
because in the past also North Korea
resumed cute assassin area some
defectors in South Korea it did happened
and the subsequent government asked me
twice in 2013 after I gave my talk if I
need security bodyguards for me but I
mean I wanted to enjoy my life really I
mean I don't know if I believe you know
the regime really want to kill me they
do I mean no matter how many cards I
have so but I only I just hope it not
happened to me you know I just the what
I'm doing is a for helping my North game
people I mean my brother's because she
says North Korea so we still fail more
Korean do you believe it can never
change of course I believe and then I
have often this worked yeah and that's
why I'm fighting right now that's why
I'm here that's why I'm sharing my story
by doing it I believe we can change
faster than we thought but also this is
not easy and it's hard to guess but I
believe it will happen in my lifetime
yeah